The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today is our final
clicker competition.
The first question is up.
And I would just like to go over
the current standing for
the clicker competition as we're
getting started here.
So, recitation 6 has two wins,
and there are other
recitations and have one win, so
recitation 2, 3, 5, 7, and
10 have one win.
If any of those recitation wins
today, we're going to go
to a tie breaker to decide the
overall recitation champion.
There are also recitations 1, 4,
9, and 11, who are looking
for their first win.
This is their last
chance today.
So, if they win today, they can
not be overall champions,
but they will have snacks,
and they will assure that
recitations 2, 3, 5, 7, and
10 do not win the overall
competition.
So, you have a chance to
foil those recitations.
And if we need to go to a tie
breaker, it will not be from
current material, it's going
to be past material or past
things that were mentioned.
So, just keep that in mind.
All right, and for the overall
winner, I just would like to
show you what you will win, so
members of the recitation will
each get their own chemistry
t-shirt, and at some schools,
of course, you would look at
this and say oh, they're on
the varsity team, but at MIT,
it means that you are
associated with course 5.
So, Department of Chemistry at
Massachusetts Institute of
Technology on the back, and we
have different colors and
different sizes.
All right, so time to get
started with the clicker
competition.
Go ahead and click in your
first responses.
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
All right.
Big improvement from the first
time we asked this question
last class where it's about
33%, now we're up to 89.
And no, it is not temperature
dependent.
And we're going to be
talking more about
activation energy today.
All right, so today we're going
to finish up kinetics,
and we're going to start with
the material that we didn't
quite get to at the
end of last class.
And I love this part, because
I love it when we can think
about what we learned before in
a slightly different way.
So, when I first started
lecturing, I was talking about
LeChatelier principle and, of
course, encouraged students to
sort of -- you know it's not too
intuitive to MIT students,
but LeChatelier's principle says
that if you apply stress
to a system, it tends to respond
in such a way to
minimize that stress.
So it's all about minimizing
stress, which is something
that's hard to kind to imagine
this time of year, a little
easier to imagine activation
energy barriers, a little hard
to imagine minimizing stress.
But we're back to talking
about minimizing stress.
And we talked about adding
reagents and removing
products, and we talked about
how reactions will shift to
respond to stresses.
And one of the things we talked
about is rationalizing
the shift of reactions at
equilibrium when temperature
has changed.
So, if you increase the
temperature of a particular
reaction, it tends to shift in
the endothermic direction to
remove that added heat
from the reaction.
So, that's what we learned
before, but now we're going to
think about this in a slightly
different way.
So we're going to think about
this in terms of these
reaction coordinate diagrams.
So, on one axis we have p e
plotted -- what does
that stand for?
Potential energy, right, so we
have potential energy going up
on both sides.
And here we have a view of an
endothermic reaction, and over
here is an exothermic
reaction.
So, let's just take
a look at this.
For the endothermic reaction,
we have reactants and
products, we have a delta e
between those, and we have a
very large activation
energy barrier
for the forward direction.
And, of course, for anything to
react, there always has to
be some barrier, you need some
amount of critical energy,
because as the molecules come
close to each other, and if
they're going to react and form
some kind of product, you
have to sort of distort bonds
and sort of rearrange things,
and that takes a certain
amount of energy.
So if they come together and
they have that energy, they'll
react and go on to products,
if they don't they'll break
apart and go back and
be reactants.
And how much temperature the
system has, is more likely
that they'll be able to react.
So it's more likely, if there's
high temperature, they
could overcome this activation
energy barrier.
All right, so in an endothermic
reaction, you have
a big one in the forward
direction, and a much smaller
activation energy in the
reverse direction.
For exothermic reaction it's
the reverse -- there's a
smaller barrier for the forward
direction, and a much
larger barrier for the
reverse direction.
So, we can think about
the sign of delta e.
So delta e, this difference here
which is related to delta
h for liquids and solids, it's
pretty much the same for gases
is 1% or 2% different.
So you have a positive value
here, and you can get a
positive delta e here if you
have a big number for the
forward activation energy
barrier minus a small number
for the reverse, so that's
going to give
you a positive number.
For an exothermic reaction,
delta e's going to be
negative, and you get a negative
number if you take a
small number here for the
forward activation energy, and
subtract it from a larger number
here for the reverse
activation energy.
And remember, this is one of the
equations that we're not
going to give you, you need to
have that memorized because
it's part of understanding
what's going on in these
diagrams.
So now let's think about what
increasing the temperature is
going to do.
So, it will help the molecules
if the is temperatures
increase, they'll have enough
energy to overcome barriers.
Now if the barriers are pretty
small, then it's not very hard
for the molecules to get over
them, regardless of the
temperature.
But when the barrier is big,
then temperature is going to
make a big difference.
And you can sort of think about
this in your own life as
you have a small assignment to
do, you just jump in and do it
and get it done and it's fine.
But if it's a very, very large
thing that you have to do, you
often need to procrastinate
longer before
you start doing it.
So, a small barrier's not so
much of a problem, but if it's
a big barrier, you need to
increase that temperature to
help the molecules get over
the bigger barriers.
So, let's think about what this
means in terms of the
direction that a reaction
might shift.
So, if you increase a
temperature over here with an
endothermic reaction, it makes
it easier to overcome the
bigger barrier.
The forward reaction barrier
is the bigger one, so
increasing the temperature will
help molecules get over
that barrier.
They're already doing fine with
the reverse barrier, it's
the forward barrier that we're
having trouble with.
So, if you increase the
temperature, that's going to
shift the equilibrium toward
products, or it will shift the
reaction in the endothermic
direction.
That's what we had learned
before with LeChatelier's
principle, but now there's a new
way of thinking about why
that is true.
So, for an exothermic reaction,
if you increase the
temperature, that helps with
the bigger barrier.
Again, here the bigger barrier
is for the reverse reaction.
So, if you increase the
temperature of an exothermic
reaction, it's going to shift
it toward reactants.
More molecules can overcome that
reverse barrier, and so
you'll form more reactants,
it'll shift toward reactants
or it'll shift in the
endothermic direction.
Again, these are the same things
that we already knew
from LeChatelier, but it's a
different way of thinking
about why those things
are true.
So, a large activation energy
barrier means that rate
constants are very sensitive
to temperature.
And so, if you have a big
activation energy barrier,
increasing the temperature makes
a big difference -- if
it's a big barrier, then there's
going to have a big
difference if you have
higher temperature.
If it's a small barrier, then
increasing the temperature
doesn't make much
of a difference.
And so you can think about
that in terms of these
diagrams as well.
So, now we're done with
temperature and we're going to
talk about catalysis and
the use of catalysts.
And so, if you remember there
were factors affecting the
reaction, and we've talked about
everything on this list
except for catalysts.
So today we're going to
talk about catalysts.
So, a catalyst is a substance
that speeds up a reaction, but
it doesn't get consumed in the
reaction, it doesn't undergo
any permanent change itself.
It's just added to speed
up the reaction.
So catalysts do not appear in
the overall balanced equation.
So let's look at what a catalyst
is going to do, and
we're going to look at in
terms of these potential
energy diagrams as well.
So here we here we have a
reaction, we're going from
reactants down here
to products.
We have the delta e for the
reaction, we have a forward
activation energy barrier
and a reverse one.
So, up here, at the top, that's
our barrier without a
catalyst. This is the transition
state or the
activated complex up here, so
you have to overcome the
barrier, you form some kind of
activated complex, which then,
if there's enough energy to
overcome that barrier, goes on
to products.
So when you add a catalyst
what happens is
it lowers this barrier.
So, in the blue line
here is the new
activation energy barrier.
This is the barrier with a
catalyst, and so this would
then be the new transition
state with a catalyst.
So when it lowers the barrier,
it's going to lower the
barrier for the forward
reaction, so we have a new
activation energy for the
forward reaction, and we're
going to have a new
activation energy
for the reverse direction.
So catalysts work by reducing
both the forward and the
reverse activation
energy barrier.
And another way that you can
say this is that they
stabilize the activated
complex or
the transition state.
So here you have an activated
complex with a much higher
potential energy without the
catalysts, and by stabilizing,
you lower in energy that
transition state.
So that's another way
of expressing
what a catalyst does.
So, catalysts have no effect on
the thermodynamics of the
reaction, they affect the
kinetics of the reaction, but
they don't affect the
thermodynamics of the reaction.
And so, of course, when you
think of thermodynamics, you
often think of delta g.
So, why don't you tell me what
you think, what would happen
about, so delta g is a state
function, it's independent of
path, and so therefore, what
can you tell me about the
equilibrium constant in the
presence of a catalyst?
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Yup, very good.
So, the equilibrium constant
is not changed.
The thermodynamics, which
includes delta g and the
equilibrium constant are not
affected, the rates of the
reaction are affected.
All right, so opposite of a
catalyst is an inhabitor, and
we'll talk more about this at
the end of class, so it would
-- inhibitor is slow or
sometimes stop the rate of the
reaction, and one way that they
do this is by increasing
the activation energy.
So let's consider types
of catalysts now.
You can have a homogeneous
catalyst, which is in the same
phase as the reaction that it's
catalyzing as the reactants.
An example of this is depletion
of the ozone layer
by chlorofluorocarbons.
And so, this was one of the big
environmental challenges
that the U.S. has faced, whether
it should ban these
chlorofluorocarbons, and there
was a lot of debate on what
the data really was about what
how much they affected the
ozone layer.
And I guess that debate is
somewhat still going on,
although I think most people now
recognize that this is a
serious problem and that
legislation is really needed
to help correct it.
So that's an example.
In this case they're all gases,
so that's homogeneous
catalyst, not a happy one.
You could also have
heterogeneous catalysts, which
are a different phase.
And here's another example
that has to do with the
environment.
So a catalytic converter is an
example of a heterogeneous
catalyst. So here you have a
solid metal surface, you can
have palladium or platinum that
will catalyze reactions
with gases, and so they
catalyze oxidation of
hydrocarbons, carbon
monoxide, also
reduction of nitrogen oxide.
So this is all to reduce
pollution.
So that's an example of a
heterogeneous catalyst. And
let me just show you a little
movie of how that might work.
So in this movie, in grey here
we have a metal surface, and
this metal surface can break
the hydrogen bond of h 2.
And so here, it is already
broken, the h 2 bond, so
there's a little hydrogen there
and hydrogen there, and
so that activates the
hydrogen to react.
And so, then we have ethene
molecule come in, and oh,
there goes the hydrogen, and oh,
there goes the hydrogen,
oh, there goes the other one
and you can form ethane.
So it speeds up the reaction
by breaking the h 2 bond so
it's more ready to react.
That would be an example of a
heterogeneous catalyst there.
All right, and, of course, you
may all have guessed that my
favorite kind of catalysts
are enzymes.
They are the catalyst of life.
And so, enzymes are made up of
protein, or mostly protein
molecules -- you can have an
enzyme that's actually made of
RNA, but most are protein
molecules.
And they're typically about
20,000 grams per mole or more,
and they're capable of carrying
out specific reactions.
And so, they're made up of amino
acids, and just to take
a quick look at that, an amino
acid has an amino group and it
has a carboxyl group, and it
has what's called an alpha
carbon that has a side chain on
it, which is abbreviated r,
and there are 20 different
types of r.
The simplest is just a hydrogen,
you could also have
a hydroxide, etc.
And so, this makes up the
alphabet of proteins, there
are 20 different ones of these
that get connected via a
peptide bond.
So at the end of this amino acid
you'd stick on the amino
group of another amino acid and
form this peptide bond.
And then you put together
hundreds and hundreds of these
to form an enzyme complex.
And so, the long chain of amino
acids folds up and forms
a compact structure.
So, in this particular picture,
there are about 200
amino acids in each of these
colored units, so this is a
tetramer, so there are four
-- there's green,
red, yellow and blue.
And so, this is what's called
a ribbon diagram.
So, these ribbons, this is an
alpha helix -- the beta
strands are long.
It traces out the position
of the alpha carbons.
And overall, this structure is
about 90 angstroms by 70
angstroms by 50 angstroms. Of
course, 1 angstroms is 1 times
10 the minus 10 meters.
So these are fairly small.
These protein molecules are,
of course, in your body.
And this particular one is
an enzyme that makes an
antibiotic, and that antibiotic
is fosfomycin,
shown here.
And so, fosfomycin is used
in antibiotic combination
therapies to treat staph
infections and other kinds of
very difficult infections
to treat.
And so, I always talk about
the things that I'm most
concerned about.
There are a lot of things that
are big threats that I don't
worry too much about.
Antibiotic resistance
is something I
actually worry a lot about.
I guess I go to too many
meetings were they talk about
problems. But the rate at
which different kinds of
bacteria are becoming resistant
to antibiotics seems
to be increasing.
So it used to take a lot longer
before a resistance
would appear than it does now.
And there really haven't been,
I think since about 1980s or
so, really new antibiotics.
So, we're still using the same
antibiotics that we have been,
which causes more things to
become immune or resistant to
those antibiotics, and I think
this is really dangerous.
And there's not enough money in
it for the pharmaceutical
industry to really
go after this.
And it's not just a problem
for biological warfare,
although that is a possibility,
but also in
hospitals, you go in for some
kind of surgery, you have to
worry about the fact that even
if the surgery goes great, you
might get an infection that
could really compromise your
health in the hospital.
And so, whether you have a heart
problem, if you have
cancer, you become immune
compromised, there's a lot, a
lot of cases where people end
up not dying of cancer
directly, they end up dying of
the bacterial infection that
can't be treated.
So this is really
a huge problem.
So I always like to let you know
all the possible problems
that you can solve
in your future.
This is one that I think is
particularly important, and I
hope some of you will focus on
this, because we really need
different kinds of antibiotics,
or we need to
change the way we do medicine
in this country so that
resistance doesn't become
as much of a
problem as it has been.
All right, so that enzyme made
an antibiotic, so we like it,
and let's talk about
how that works.
How that particular series of
amino acids folds up to do
that reaction.
So now we have some new
nomenclature, and sometimes
when people get into the
biochemistry world they get
scared because there are all
these words that they don't
know what they mean.
So most of them are not -- they
are things that you can
relate back to something
you already know.
So, we've been talking about
reactants, and when you have a
reactant with an enzyme, it's
usually called a substrate.
So this is just another name
for a reactant molecule.
And then substrates tend to
bind in what we call the
active site of the enzyme,
which is the part of the
enzyme that's going to
do the chemistry.
So those are two terms that
you'll hear about in
biochemistry.
All right, so we have an enzyme,
we'll call it e, it
binds a substrate, we'll call
that s, and then it forms an
enzyme substrate complex,
which we'll call an e s
complex, for enzyme substrate.
And then that enzyme substrate
complex will go to enzyme and
product, which we'll call p.
And if you look in the
state-of-the-art biochemistry
books, these are the
abbreviations you'll see in
there as well.
So, this pains me greatly to
show this cartoon, because I
spend my career determining
3-dimensional structures of
proteins, and so to describe
it as a little squiggly is
painful for me.
But nonetheless, there you go.
Also, the substrate is almost
about as big as the enzyme.
That is also usually not true.
But nonetheless, here's
a little cartoon.
Here's our substrate binding to
our enzyme, it's forming an
e s complex.
And then the enzyme is going
to move the ears of the
substrate around to
form product, and
now product is released.
So, this is actually pretty
simple in terms
of writing a mechanism.
And so, what we can do is write
a mechanism the way that
we have been writing
a mechanism
so far in this class.
And so we're going to go through
this, we're going to
derive expression mostly to show
you that all the things
you've been learning are related
to chemistry, they're
also related to biochemistry.
So, you already know a lot
of biochemistry from just
studying freshman chemistry
in 511-1.
All right, so we have 2 steps
in our mechanism.
We have enzyme binding
substrate to form an
intermediate enzyme substrate
complex, which then goes on to
form enzyme plus product
in step 2.
So the first step is reversible,
the second step is
not as drawn.
All right, so now we can come up
with the rates for each of
the individual steps in this
overall mechanism, and since
they are elementary reactions
or steps in an overall
mechanism, we can write the rate
laws directly from what
we observe.
So for the forward direction,
we're going to
have what rate constant?
K 1 times the concentration
of what?
And?
Yeah.
So there we go.
We have k 1 times the
concentration of e and the
concentration of s.
See, you already knew how
to do biochemistry.
All right, so now at the rate of
the reverse direction is --
what's our rate constant?
K minus 1 times e s.
And then for step 2, we have
what rate constant?
K 2 times e s.
All right, so now we can
talk about the rate
formation of product.
And so you'll see this expressed
as d concentration
of p d t, so the change in
product that's being formed
and that's going to be equal
to the second step
here, k 2 times e s.
But, as has been the case
before, e s is an
intermediate, and we need to
solve our rate laws, our rate
expressions, in terms
of reactants or
products and rate constants.
So we need to solve for
the intermediate.
All right, so let's think
about solving for the
intermediate.
And why don't you tell
me how to do that.
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Very good.
All right, so let's just
take a look at
why that is the case.
So, when we solve for this, it's
going to be equal to the
formation of the intermediate,
which happens in the first
step with this rate that you
told me, k 1 times the
concentration of e s.
And then we have the
decomposition in the reverse
of step one, so that's
minus k minus 1 e s.
And then we also have the
consumption of the
intermediate, which is -- so we
have minus this step, which
is k 2 times e s.
So again, formation minus
decomposition minus
consumption.
And now, we can use the steady
state approximation.
So the steady state
approximation applies in
biochemistry just as well as
in all of your chemistry
problems that you've done
in this course.
And so, the steady state
approximation allows us to set
that whole term equal to zero.
So it says that the net rate of
intermediate formation and
decomposition and consumption is
0, or you can express it as
the rate of formation of the
intermediate equals the rates
of decomposition and consumption
-- those are
equivalent.
So we can set all of
this equal to zero.
So again, the same as what
we've done before.
All right, so now we're going
to have a slight change of
what we've done before, and
this has to do with the
practical consideration.
So you can solve for these
in terms of reactants and
products and rate constants,
but it's actually easier to
solve for e s in terms of your
total enzyme rather than your
free enzyme.
So what we've had before is our
free enzyme, but we often
don't know how much enzyme is
free, and by that we mean not
bound to the substrate.
And so, we know how much total
enzyme we put in, but we might
not know how much of
that is unbound.
So it's actually easier for the
experimentalist to solve
for things in terms
of total enzyme.
And so what we're going to do
then is we're going to replace
our free enzyme term with the
following, total enzyme minus
bound, and total enzyme
minus the bound
enzyme is the free enzyme.
So we're going to do this change
that makes it easier
for the experimentalist.
So here's the term we had
before, but now we want to
replace this term of e with
e to 0 minus e s.
So we're going to put that,
here's the term e up here, so
we're going to replace that
with e 0 minus e s.
And then we're going to multiply
that out, so we get k
1, e 0, s minus k 1, e s, and
then the concentration of
substrate here, and the rest
of it is the same.
So we got rid of our term e.
So now we can solve for e s.
So this is what we just had,
and so we're going to
rearrange so the e s terms are
on one side, so we have an e s
term here, here, and here.
So all that is going to be on
one side, and then this other
term will be on the other
side of the equation.
So now we have moved all the e
s terms over here, so we've
got rid of the negative numbers,
we've added them all
to the other side, and then on
this side we just have this k
1 term left.
Now we're going to pull
out the e s terms. So,
we'll solve for e s.
We'll pull that out, that leaves
us with k 1 times the
concentration of s, k minus
1, and then k 2.
And now we're going to take this
and divide by that term
in parentheses, and so now we've
solved for e s in terms
of total enzyme substrate
and our rate constants.
All right, now we're going
to do another thing
that's a bit different.
We're going to introduce a term
in biochemistry, which is
k m, also known as the
Michaelis-Menten constant, and
so k m is equal to the
rate constant for the
forward/reverse direction, k
minus 1 plus k 2 over k 1.
So we're going to now try to
use this in our expression.
So we're going to put this term
in there, and so to have
this term of k m in there,
we need to have this
divided by k 1.
So we can do that, it's OK, as
long as we divide everything
by k 1, so we're going to divide
the top by k 1, and
this by k 1, and that by k 1.
So now, we divide all by k 1,
and so we have this top with k
1, this term with k 1, and
this with k 1, and
that's our k m value.
But now we can simplify this,
we've got a lot of k 1's here,
and so if we simplify this,
we can cross out
those k 1's over there.
And we can also get rid of
these k 1's over here.
And that's going to leave
us with a much simpler
expression.
So that's going to leave us with
the total enzyme times
substrate over substrate
plus k m.
And that looks a whole lot
better than that other term
that we had before.
OK, so we can now take this and
substitute it back into
the expression we had earlier.
So here we had the rate of
product formation, k 2 times
this intermediate, we solved
for the intermediate using
total enzyme and using
this k m term.
And now we just put all
of this times k 2.
And if you put all of that
times k 2, you have this
expression, which is the
Michaelis-Menten equation.
So the only difference of what
you did before was that you
solved in terms of total enzyme,
and also, we have this
new k m term.
And so now we have an equation
that's used in a lot of
biochemistry research to think
about enzyme kinetics.
So let's think about enzyme
kinetics for a minute.
This is what a plot often looks
like -- we are looking
at the product formed by
an enzyme versus the
concentration of substrate.
And it often goes up.
It's pretty steep, and then
it starts to level off.
So let's think about what's
happening here.
So if you have low substrate,
so that's way down here, not
much substrate is available,
adding more substrate will
increase this rate
significantly, you'll form a
lot more product, it increases
the rate of product formation.
Because a lot of the
enzyme is free and
can react with substrate.
So it goes up, but then the
rate starts to level off.
So when you got to higher
substrate concentrations,
adding more substrate does not
affect the rate much, the rate
is leveling off.
And we say that the enzyme
is saturated.
All the enzyme that you have in
there already has substrate
going on, it's already
doing the chemistry.
So if you're throwing more at
it, the enzyme can't bind that
substrate, it's busy with a
different substrate molecule.
So all the active sites in the
enzyme are full, and so not
much happens.
So this kind of graph
is what you often
see in enzyme kinetics.
Now let's think about
that in terms of our
Michaelis-Menten equation.
So let's think about conditions
when there's a lot
of substrate, when substrate
is much greater than k m.
So here we have substrate and
k m on the bottom of our
equation, and what's going to
happen if this term is much,
much bigger than
this k m term?
What happens to the k m term?
It goes away.
It's really small compared
to this, it's kind of
insignificant.
So, if that happens, then you
can cancel substrate as well.
And so, that means that under
conditions where substrate is
much greater than k m, the rate
is a much simpler term,
it's just equal to k 2 times
your total enzyme.
And so this has a name, this is
called Vmax or the maximum
velocity of the reaction.
So, under these conditions,
when the substrate is much
greater than that k m value,
this expression simplifies and
you get just k 2, your rate
constant, times your total
enzyme, and that'll give
you the maximum
velocity of the reaction.
And so, that's just written
again here.
Vmax equals k 2 times total
enzyme, and that equation will
be given to you on an
equation sheet.
So what's happening?
What's happening is that
you're up here.
So when substrate concentration
is much greater
than k m, then you're in these
conditions, and you're at some
maximum velocity.
So the velocity will only go,
the rate of the reaction will
only go so fast, it will
saturate, it'll level off up
here, and so you can calculate
that maximum
rate of that reaction.
Now let's consider what happens
when your substrate
concentration equals your k m.
So down here, if k m is equal to
substrate, then we're going
to have two substrates
down here.
And so, we can write this, if
they're equal, we can write
this as substrate plus
substrate, and then we can do
some canceling.
So this will be equal to 2
substrates and then we can
cancel that out, and so we get
the rate of product formation
under conditions where substrate
equals k m of 1/2 k
2 times the total enzyme
concentration.
And this is referred to
the half maximal rate.
Remember, the maximal rate was
k 2 times this e knot, and so
half of that is half the
maximal rate here.
So, the definition of k m is the
concentration of substrate
for which the rate
is half maximal.
So if your rate is half of the
maximum rate, that substrate
concentration that gives you
half the maximum rate, is the
value for k m.
Substrate concentration equals
k m at the half maximal rate.
So let's just look at
what that meant.
So if this is Vmax up here, half
of Vmax is here, half of
that value, and the substrate
concentration at half Vmax is
equal to k m.
So you can write those
in on your diagram.
Vmax is this velocity up here,
half of that, when you're at
half of the maximal rate,
k m equals the substrate
concentration.
And there will be problems that
you will work in your
book very shortly, and often,
the problems just have to do,
they'll give you the information
in words and the
calculations can often
be pretty simple.
Sometimes it'll say, figure
out what the k m for this
reaction is.
At this substrate concentration,
the rate is
half maximal.
Well, at that substrate
concentration, that's the k m.
So, a lot of the problems are
sort of word problems, they
give you the information and
you need to know what the
definitions are.
But let's try an example.
So here in this example, we've
talked about buffering in the
blood, so the conversion of
your ingredients that make
your buffering agent in the
blood, that can be catalyzed
by an enzyme called
carbonicanhydrase, and the
following Michaelis-Menten
constants are known, a k m is
known, and a k 2 is known, and
if you're doing experiment and
you have a total concentration
of your enzyme of 5 times 10
to the minus 6 molar, then you
should be able to figure out
what the maximum rate of
the reaction would be.
So, why don't you go ahead
and tell me what the
maximum rate would be.
OK, let's just take
10 more seconds.
Very good.
Everyone's doing very
good today.
All right, so all you have to
do, you have remember Vmax
equals your total enzyme
concentration times your k 2.
And pretty much no one, hardly
anyone was fooled
by k m value there.
All right, very good.
So there are extra problems on
enzyme kinetics posted on the
extra problems posted
on the Web.
So there's a few there, so you
can see the type of problems,
again, they're like that,
they're pretty simple.
If you remember the definition
of k m, and you'll be given
the equation for Vmax, you
should be able to handle the
enzyme/kinetics problems
pretty well.
Often, also I'll ask questions
like explain why at high
substrate concentrations, the
rate does not increase very
much, or why the graph levels
off, or I might ask you to
draw the plot and tell me
about low substrate
concentrations, what's true
there, and high substrate
concentrations, what's true.
So those are the types of
questions you're going to get
on enzyme kinetics, they're
actually pretty simple.
All right, so let's just talk
briefly about enzyme
inhibition.
So the opposite of catalysis
-- instead of binding a
substrate, you'll bind
an inhibitor.
So often, these are actually
pretty simple.
An inhibitor sometimes will look
a lot like a substrate or
like a transition complex, and
it'll blind to the enzyme.
And when you have that inhibitor
stuck in the active
site, substrate physically can't
bind, so it occupies the
place that substrate goes,
substrate will come in but it
can't bind anywhere.
So this is actually the
mechanism by which a number of
pharmaceuticals work.
So, one thing that people who
were designing enzyme
inhibitors think about is the
fact that enzymes do tend to
stabilize a transition state
in the reaction.
So if you make an inhibitor that
resembles a transition
state, it should bind to the
enzyme more tightly than
either the reactants, the
substrates, or the products.
So, a lot of the pharmaceutical
industry likes
to try to figure out what the
transition state might look
like, and then try to make a
molecule that looks like that
transition state that hopefully
will blind to the
enzyme active site and prevent
the enzyme from doing what
it's supposed to do.
So, just to kind of look back
at this figure for a minute
that you had earlier in your
notes, so you have the
transition state is often
stabilized by a catalyst, and
so an enzyme will also stabilize
a transition state.
So if you make your drug look
like a transition state, it
will hopefully bind
very tightly.
And so this is one of the sort
of principles that's behind a
lot of the pharmaceuticals that
have made to treat HIV
infections.
So I mentioned last week we
had world AIDS day, that
understanding kinetics
was actually very
important in HIV research.
And so, many of the
pharmaceuticals that are given
to HIV patients are what are
called protease inhibitors.
So they inhibit enzymes that are
called proteases, and if
you have ase at the end of the
name that means it's an
enzyme, and so protease means
that it's an enzyme that
cleaves proteins.
It's a protein ase.
And so, how do these
enzymes work.
Well, they cleave other
proteins, they cleave peptide
bonds, and so you often have
some kind of either activated
water or other hydroxide
molecule that will attack here
the carbonyl of a peptide
bond, and it forms a
tetrahedral intermediate, which
then collapses and it
cleaves that peptide bond.
So the peptide bond is then
broken, so that's what a
protease does, and a
protease inhibitor
prevents that cleavage.
So often, protease inhibitors
look like tetrahedral
intermediates, and so they'll
bind to the protease active
site and prevent the chemistry
from occurring.
So if it's a tetrahedral
intermediate, what kind of
angles should some
pharmaceutical company be
looking for in its compounds?
109 .
5, yes.
So, molecules with this stable
tetrahedral intermediate
somewhere on the molecule could
bind to the active site
and prevent a catalysis.
So, let me just show you one
example of an improved HIV
drug, and there it is.
This is the tetrahedral site
that binds at the active site
of that enzyme, and the enzyme
can't cleave this tetrahedral
intermediate, and so this just
binds, but the enzyme can't
work on it, so it just sits
there and prevents substrate
from binding.
So that's how a lot of
these compounds work.
And so, this is just a little
picture of the enzyme active
site and there's an inhibitor
bound to the enzyme active
site, and so a number of
companies are working on
trying to come up with better
and better inhibitors that
will sit in the HIV protease
active site.
So, knowledgeable of a reaction
mechanism can lead to
new therapeutic treatments.
So, one question with this, with
protease, there are a lot
of proteases, not just the ones
involved with HIV, and so
one real problem is specificity
and toxicity, so
you want to have a drug that
inhibits one enzyme and not
all the enzymes in
that category.
So that's a big problem in the
pharmaceutical industry.
So, apparently, clicker results,
we actually need to
break a tie.
But we can't do it now.
OK, so Justin's section, woah!
So, apparently we're having, we
have the questions ready,
but apparently they're
not ready to be used
right at the moment.
So, we're going to use low tech
here and indicate the
results for today.
And then on Wednesday, last
day of class -- oh, my
goodness, so close.
Recitation 6, you were second.
All right, so on Wednesday then,
we're going to have the
tie breaker, and review
and evaluations.